the jurogan experience
it's it's it's funny to me because um
i get it all the time
now
of course like people people accuse me
all the time and um
and i haven't really told the story but
so i one day i i saw like people kept
tagging me in this video
and there was this some [ __ ] guy some
dumbass that's on youtube that
that swears he can spot people that do
you know pds oh that's probably more
plates more dates
maybe yeah i don't know i don't know
derek he's been on the podcast yeah so
he's like yeah i know that guy's doing
it because i can see the marks on him
and stuff like that and
so he starts to point they they start
pointing out because i have uh like
like five scars on my stomach
like you know like burn like discolor
coloration on my stomach and it and he
starts to start pointing at that and he
starts talking about it and and making
up this whole theory
and it kind of
it kind of hurt my feelings a little bit
because
it should make it
okay so this here's a story i was a
little self-conscious about it because
so this is what happened i was in
college this was my
i want to say junior year
sophomore junior year
going into my junior season
and
uh actually i think it was after my
junior season so
i i started getting these i got it like
a mole on like my stomach
and i got one like on my my hand and i
i'm one of those i'm kind of like a
clean freak like i shower
you know after practice right away
so i start scratching it
and then it starts bleeding
so i'm like [ __ ] that's not irregular i
thought it was like a pimple that's not
a regular like a zit or something like
that
so
then i you know over time it was like
maybe it was like five little was like
tiny you could barely see them so i'm
like you know what i'm gonna ask the doc
we have a team doctor
i'm gonna ask him about it so i went in
for a physical and then i went before
the season i asked him hey
you know i have this right here i don't
know what they are
so he looks at him he goes oh these are
non-cancerous moles they're just little
bitty moles you know it's very very
common i'm like [ __ ] not for me i don't
know that's
common for me he's like yeah they're
very common
i'm like yeah well how can i get rid of
him i try to scratch him and they
bleeding he's like yeah you don't do
that
what we could do is we can burn them off
and i'm like
okay [ __ ] it let's do it because hey uh
spring break was gonna come up
like i i started i started
i started i'm lifting now i got a body
now you know i'm uh you know i'm
a junior and i i've looked jacked so i'm
like spring break is coming i want to
look jack i want to look good you know
so i don't get walking around with those
[ __ ] no
so
he's like i could burn him off so he
burns him off with that thing nitrogen
or something like that
so he burns them and then he goes hey
those are going to fall off in a couple
days you know just give them time
so i'm like okay but i was so like
i was still training heavily during the
summer because i was just like an addict
of wrestling i wanted to
for me i wanted to get catch up to
everybody and i wanted to exceed
everybody so this was my time the summer
that that was my time for me to catch up
so
my dumb ass
i go back the next day i go to school
and um
back to the school and i go in and i go
drill i go wrestle i couldn't stop i was
just training all summer so i wrestled
and i didn't think anything of it was
like okay they just burned those but
nothing has happened yet
and so i wrestled
and then later that evening i'm sitting
in my i go i get down i get in the
shower
and i'm showering all of a sudden just
burning down there and i looked down
and i had like scraped them off
like so as soon as he burned him he said
don't do anything they're gonna fall off
on their own but my dumb ass wrestled
and it rubbed up against it and now they
all fell off so then they scarred it
because now i was like out for like
seven days like putting neosporin on it
just so they can heal
and then they scarred over so i have
those from just that moment so then this
[ __ ] guy is like oh he's he's doing
pds look look he's got the marks on his
stomach and he hurt my feelings i'm like
i'm i'm like one of those guys who i'm
like
i don't even think about peds because my
work even if i don't care i probably
have
dealt with someone that was cheating or
competed against someone that was
cheating but my work will far exceed all
of that and so when i see idiots online
or saying oh yeah i know for a fact he's
doing pd i'm like have you ever been a
[ __ ] africa
have you been to africa there's a lot of
francis and ghana's walking around
[Laughter]
there's a lot of guys like me just
walking around
and because of the work and because of
the way that i fight they're like oh no
he's definitely got to be doing
something because they can't explain
why
you are the way you are why your
performance exceeds what their their
mind is mentally capable of there's a
photo of you we're on top of the cage
after one of the victories yeah and
you're like this like
it looks preposterous like if i didn't
know any better i'd be like that
[ __ ] on some
[ __ ] it's um genetics are real
genetics are real this is not everybody
did not get the same deck of cards oh
yeah yeah that one look at that one come
on son if i if i saw that [ __ ]
if someone said do you think this guy's
on the juice i'm like highly likely yeah
adrenaline
you know and i think this yeah this is
right after uh the mosfet all five